[موسيقى]
كل سنه وقناتي العربيه بخير وسعاده وتالق
بمناسبه مرور 20 سنه ويا رب عقبال 100 سنه
من النجاح والتنوير
20 سنه يا مرقوا وسنين جايه من التقدم
والنجاح والاستمراريه ينعاد عليكم نانسي
عجرم
[موسيقى]
اهني قناه العربيه ومنسوبيه قناه العربيه
والقائمين عليها
بمناسبه مرور 20 سنه على انطلاقه بثها
واذا هناك جمله مني انا اقدر اقول انا
اتابع قناه العربيه منذ عشرين سنه
تحياتي
كل سنه وقناه العربيه القناه الرائده اللي
بتنقلنا اهم الاخبار القناه اللي فيها جزء
من يومياتنا من سنين طويله عشرين سنه ان
شاء الله هيك تلحقها 200 سنه و2000 سنه من
النجاح ومن التقدم دائما كل سنه وانتم
بالف خير
صبحكم الله بالخير جميعا اهني قناتنا
الرائعه والاكثر من رائعه العربيه بمناسبه
مرور 20 عام على تاسيسها من قلبك دوام
الموفقيه والنجاح
العربيه على طول من اهم القنوات اللي
موجوده وبتفيد المجتمع والعالم كله كل سنه
وقناه العربيه طيبه على مرور 20 سنه
[موسيقى]